all right troy
yeah troy where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um the riverside
area uh born in orange
county tell me about your family growing
up
you had mom and dad yeah very good
childhood
um
great parents uh
i probably had the ideal childhood
made through high school
yeah
and a little bit of college well good
for you
where'd your life go after school
um
my uncle is in a biker gang
and so
i kind of hung out
with them
a little bit more than part-time
but uh
started a small business and got married
yeah kids
i have two daughters now
and um my son
was was killed
i'm sorry
how did that happen
um
where we were living back in the
back in the hills there was no water so
we had a well
and the foot valve got jammed up with
sand so i had to stay home and work on
it
my mother came to pick us all up to take
us to this petting zoo
and uh i couldn't go i had to fix the
the pump
so my wife and my mom went
with my son the baby who was six months
and not far from the house
a drunk driver went off the road
spun around came back on the road and
hit them head-on
and
i don't know if my wife went completely
through the glass
but my son did at six months
and my mom had a concussion
so bad that
she didn't know who we were
um
when she started to get better she would
say things like
troy get the cat out of the microwave
like if something was cooking
everything was jumbled up in her head
so you lost your wife
no no my my
i lost my son
my wife made it oh she survived yeah but
she psychologically was
pretty messed up
and my mom
i still have my mom but
it looks like my mom
she sounds like my
mom but
i don't recognize her
when she speaks
from the concussion i guess
it just changed her
completely
and the drunk driver
yeah he survived or died he survived
for a short time
what do you mean
well while we were going to court he
would come in and you could see that he
obviously was still drinking
and he would make comments like it was
my mom's fault because she was speeding
um
then when that didn't play out then he
made comments that it was my wife's
fault for holding the baby on the
in the front seat
in 91 that was a common thing
there weren't seat belt laws like
there are now
or
[Music]
child seat laws like now
back then everyone held their kid in the
front seat
and
so well my son went through the glass
i'm sorry is this it's real difficult
for me
so yeah now he's gone
but i have two daughters
after the court was about to end
we found out that the guy was going to
get probation
he had a good legal defense
and
[Music]
at the time we didn't have a lot of
money
and uh
so i just i couldn't see things going on
the way they were
i took matters into my own hands
uh a friend of mine who's my height and
same hair color
we went to las vegas
and i cast a check under the camera so
they could see my face
we sat down at two slot machines
then after a bit we went in the bathroom
and changed clothes
where he went back and sat where i sat
i hopped on the motorcycle and came back
and i used the 45
and knocked down this door
i left all my motorcycle gear on so that
i was
disguised
no one could id me
there weren't cameras like there are
today
and when you came to the door
and i
emptied the clip right into its head
and then hopped on my bike
and came back to vegas
and
i got away with it for
over a year
i was interviewed because today i was
the number one suspect of course
i was interviewed
thoroughly but they were convinced it
wasn't me because of my alibi
well
my uncle in the biker gang i told him
all about it
and he thought that was just the coolest
thing
so i told them everything in detail
and then
one night
i guess drinking because
alcohol runs in my
in that side of my family
heavily
he told my aunt which is my mom's sister
and then one night
my aunt got to talking to my mom
after she healed from the concussion
not realizing my mom had changed
so much
and
my mom was outraged
out just outraged
and uh
we had gotten an argument one day
and
she
called the fbi
and she told them
so there was an arrest warrant out for
me
and actually it was just a warrant for
questioning
which but i knew what that meant
so i was on the run for quite a while
almost a
year and that was that really sucked
um we moved all the time
i couldn't do anything
being on the run being on a run must be
a hard lifestyle it is it's really bad
and then
with all my kids and my wife
we got pulled over
and i gave him a fake name
i tried really hard to make it past
but uh
no they had been looking for me for too
hard
for too long
and the cops said they were just going
to take me down take my picture had me
sign some papers and they'd let me go
i pretty much knew better
but once they put the cuffs on me that
was it
it was over
i kind of felt relieved
being on the run
it's exhausting
what's the worst part of being on the
run like that hello it was a year
almost a year
what's the worst part of that
having to have enough money to to
have your family your daughter not say
dad i'm hungry
because you couldn't work anywhere yeah
i could just do side jobs or deal drugs
or modify guns
my
family's all gunsmiths and
in the gun trade heavily
so i'm very familiar with guns
so you eventually did time
yeah i ended up getting sentenced to 15
years
for murder yeah
and uh
while i was locked up the
feds approached me with this
psychoanalyzing
tests that
if i did it they would
modify my sentence and give me half time
but the
thing was i said that
if there's any level of
um
if everything isn't 100 true
if there's any dishonest remarks
we'll find out by the test
and then your half time won't uh
you won't get it
so it had to be
everything i said had to be accurate
excuse me did you get your time reduced
yeah they uh they gave they gave me half
time
so i ended up doing seven years nine
months
in of all places folsom
i think the judge had something to do
with that
because they were
[Music]
one of the things the judge told me is
i didn't act remorseful at all
and the judge was bitter about that
and he told me he said well
one thing that you're not realizing
is that you destroyed two families
not just one
and
i wasn't sure what he meant
he said well his family doesn't have a
father
no yours doesn't
that's when it kind of hit home
everyone i talk to and
tell about this they say
oh i'd have done the same thing
but
after all is said and done
my life would have been better
if i wouldn't
shout them
yeah change things significantly
do you think you would have been able to
forgive
that's the thing the guy wasn't
remorseful at all so
uh
i don't know
would have to know what i know now
which hindsight you know
it's a real tough one
when when people
tell me right away oh i'd have done the
same thing
that's when i start to think that maybe
it wasn't such a great idea
because when someone's dead
there's nothing you can do to bring him
back
you've been out for how long now
i got out right before 2000
and having that
type of crime on my record
has
sent me back
three times
my wife got caught with drugs
in her purse
and i didn't want her to go to jail so
i said they were mine
and they easily gave me three years for
that
and uh
and then
after that one other time
i got caught stealing
from the store
and i got 16 months for that
something somebody else would have got
probation on
so yeah the laws come down real hard on
me
now that my record's so blemished
no more chances
where do you stay now you've been
homeless for a while
yeah i've been staying with friends
uh right now and staying in a friend's
garage
my marriage is gone
where do you stay when you're homeless
on the street
are drugs a part of your life now yeah
they are uh
i do drugs because it helps numb
my
feeling of guilt
and
in los angeles
when people are homeless they stay where
they can stay indoors when it's warm
and a lot of times that requires
getting on the subway
and riding the subway till late at night
but they kick you off at like 12 30
so from 12 30 to about 3 30
you're you're walking the street
but
at 3 34
you can get back into the subway
if it's real cold or if it's raining
not the ideal situation
what drug do you use
um i was first introduced to heroin in
prison
and
since i've
got off heroin and i've been doing
fentanyl
how do you support yourself then
uh right now
middle-manning drug deals
um i was giving guitar lessons at the
park for a while
but i uh
i got jumped one night beat up and
they took my guitar
some uh street thugs
and you can't carry a guitar around late
at night
in this neighborhood
and then
small crime
pays for my drugs
when i get desperate
but i make sure i don't do anything
substantial
nothing serious
i don't want to ever go back
but it wouldn't take much
so i have to be very careful
how do you deal with all this
emotionally
and sometimes i go and sit by myself and
i can't stop
crying and but drugs numb me
basically it's the drugs
it keeps me sane
keeps me focused
otherwise i can't uh
see things through
you would think that you would be able
to forget something and and put it
aside but
as many years as it's been
since 2000
when i got out
right before 2000
the events
surrounding this
it's the last thing i think of at night
and the first thing when i wake up
today
it's a lot to carry around with you
it is
there was a point in time when i felt
very remorseful
and wanted to apologize to his family
but
if i even go near that family
it's uh like a four-year
sentence so
i thought of maybe writing a letter but
any communication at all
i can't do it how old are you now
54.
you have hope of turning your life
around or
i enjoy
i do
i do and i've been trying to get into
this rehab
i've never been in a rehab program
that i wanted to go to
where i wanted to quit drugs
i've been forced into one
by my mom once
by my wife once
but never really wanted to clean up
until now
how's your wife doing now
uh she moved to north dakota
with your daughters with one of my
daughters
the one that doesn't talk to me
she thinks that
excuse me
all the years i was gone i left because
i didn't love her
and
my other daughter
her and i are still friends but
we haven't talked in over a year
i haven't talked to my mom in over 14
years
she's a different person
after the concussion is that because of
her concussion or because of your drug
addiction or because of what you did
here it's everything
it's everything the whole package yeah
14 years is a long time
what are you afraid of now
um
going back to prison
but
i think the biggest thing i'm afraid of
is not
having a family again
i want to see them
do you believe in karma
do i believe in karma
absolutely
does karma play out in your life
well
it's funny that you say that
because i kind of made a deal with
god and i know god's not one to make
deals with but
i prayed a lot that
if i could get out and do things
different
i wouldn't hurt anyone ever again
so i try to follow that
my uh uncle that was involved with the
motorcycle gang
he was a good friend and
i had a lot of friends through that
but since he's passed and
all my friends are gone
really i'm alone
i haven't sat down
and talked about this this thoroughly
ever
what's your biggest regret
of all this
um
the harm it caused my kids
breaking up my family
the stress on my parents
for for that reason
[Music]
i would go back and change things
if i'd have known
i was going to wake up old and bitter
i wouldn't have done it
are you old and bitter no
i try not to be but i think i might
i just think i might be
i try not to be too bitter
troy what would you say is the most
important lesson
you've learned from all of this
you really have to sit down and think
about
what everyone's life is going to be like
after you take things into your hands
not just yours
what
how is this going to affect everyone
i never gave it one second of the
thought
of how this would affect my mom
not at all
nor did i
think about how it would affect my kids
i didn't think i was going to get caught
i had the greatest alibi
i thought
but uh
yeah see how it damaged
everyone
it
if i could turn the hands of time back
i should have focused and found another
way
to handle my anger
but i was pretty proud of myself after i
did that
it really was
loose lips sing ships
that is a fact
yeah if you want to keep something a
secret even telling one person
you might as well
sign the affidavit
and mail it to the judge
would holding that secret around the
rest of your life
be similar to being on the run
so it's a lot of weight to carry around
yeah
but if i had my family back
i think i could have maybe coped with
things better it's really difficult
handling things
alone
when you were a young man did you have
any
inkling that your life would have been
so complicated
no messy no
and all my mom ever wanted was a big
family
and i i gave that to them
my brother doesn't have any kids
and so i got married and had kids
so it kind of completed
the family unit
grandma grandpa everyone
it was really beautiful
for a while
but it's funny everyone that i talk to
tells me they do
the same thing but
they don't have all the facts
they don't know what my life's like now
i'm a strong individual after going
through that that's all they see
that's all anyone sees
all right troy thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
from here
thank you i appreciate it thank you
you